bon là contre au delà champ social
france à ckoi pour exaucer tes prières
mortel au québec selon moi c'était quand
la dernière fois que tu as fait tes mots
enfin bon tu l'a jamais fait on dit à
nos parents qu'on se fait virer aux
grands lacs et au lieu de ça on passe
tes soeurs espère polir le blanc par des
filles canadiennes dans ce tri merde
c'est marrant j'ai pu aussi nous ils
vont le retrouver
bossi canadiennes et actions gratuites
parfait tu fais quoi là j'ai tué ma
carte estime pourquoi le savoir ce qui
se passe dans mon van ce que tu as
trouvé un lieu qui s'adresse aux gens
comme je sais où il s'arrête c'est qu'on
va où la levade hockey et on fera quoi
quand on y sera vous êtes au courant le
club allait pas s'ils appuient ses
cartes
je crois qu'il commence à gérer
à nos élections qu'elles nous rendent
fiers
merci à toi de quoi pour tout ça
j'ai un truc à vous demander c'est un
peu gênant alors vous foutez pas de ma
gueule évidemment titov asie il faut
quelqu'un me rester cool non mexes est
mort j'ai obligé d'assister m